it would be a very bad move on his end  to do anything to us because he's gonna  need u.s long term to protect them in  case something happens with china  because china's the guy that's standing  alone by themselves buying up all these  small different places they're  buying the cobalt in uh you know uh  africa they're you know their their  strategy with iran with oil the way  they're taking it is a very different  strategy on how china's taking it  would you say the same thing would you  agree with that that russia needs  america to make sure long-term they're  protected from china  the russians are chess players and i  think that that analysis  is possibly the way the russians are  thinking about this and it's even  possible that  that one of the reasons they have we  haven't been attacked yet is precisely  because  of that that they that they need us in  the long run looking toward world war iv